those of you waiting for the new M2 iPad
Pros the redesigned budget iPads new Mac
Minis and MacBook Pros well we have some
bad news Mark German from Bloomberg once
again reiterated that we will most
likely not see an October event and that
is for a few reasons that I will explain
but I might just have a different
opinion and if I'm wrong I think this
news could be even worse we've been
covering a variety of Apple products
that should be coming out this year not
only based on leaks but actual proof
with products that have been registered
but not yet released and a lot of them
should be coming out this month in
October but Mark Airman is saying that
they might be announced through a press
release instead of an event and that is
because there are not enough changes to
Warrant this event for example we have
the M2 iPad Pro which is not getting a
full redesign but is going to be getting
some new features for example Max safe
wireless charging support and a glass
back now personally that scares me to
have a glass back on the iPad Pro and we
reported that Apple hit a roadblock with
that so I'm kind of glad now Vadim
talked about an option to have the
actual Apple logo be the part that will
transmit uh the charging and possibly
even data so that seems like a much
better solution and of course another
change being the M2 Chip now even as far
as June it was being shown off that it
will launch in September or October but
now it could be just a press release now
on this one I will say it is very
believable for me because the M2 Chip
and the M2 MacBook Air in Pro wasn't as
big of a deal as we expected of course
we saw that the power usage shot way up
and the performance didn't go up that
much but what did impress me was the
power efficiency with those efficiency
cores so that could be a benefit but
overall not a lot of people really need
this update now what people have been
waiting for are 14 and 16 inch MacBook
Pros with new three nanometer chips
being included in there now we know that
apple is working on production design
for this and we've had many solid
reports that Apple be the first to use
this three nanometer technology and they
will be putting it into the M2 Pro and
Max ships instead of using five
nanometer like on the M2 MacBook Air and
we've had many reputable sources talking
about this and how revolutionary it will
be so this is the first part that
doesn't make sense for Apple to just do
a press release on a chip that has a
similar name but much better
capabilities including not only better
performance but what I think is more
important less heat because even right
now the 16 inch MacBook Pros do throttle
if you're pushing them to the Limit just
because of the amount of heat that is
put out if this is going to be the case
I do not see how Apple could just do a
press release but we also have the
option of Apple people still using five
nanometer for these laptops because it's
too early or something else went wrong
and in that case there's really no
reason to show it off to make this worse
Apple has reportedly rejected tsmc's
price hike for new chips and of course
apple has a lot of weight because they
buy so many chips but if they're trying
to make this three nanometer work the
fastest possible get enough Supply how
can they just say sorry we're not going
to pay it unless they're willing to wait
on those chips now we know that tech
product sales have been down across the
board of consumers having to spend more
money on regular items like gas and
other things like groceries because
everything's been so much more expensive
and now we see the iPhone 14 sales have
also been quite bad and we have this new
report saying that the iPhone 14 is
depreciated and valued more than twice
as much as the 13 in the same time frame
which that wasn't a big upgrade either
so Apple could be taking the safer route
doing less expensive updates for example
the M2 MacBook Pro was a very clear case
of this same thing for these MacBooks
it's just getting a slight bump with the
five nanometer version of those chips
and just releasing it as a press event
now what doesn't make sense to me are
some other products now sure we have the
new Mac Mini that was shown to be a
redesigned version then people are
talking about it maybe staying the same
if Apple doesn't change anything there
that could easily be a press event but
my opinion is with this new 10th
Generation budget iPad seeing a redesign
with the new flat sides with USB type c
and it being a 10 generation product the
decade product which is important for
Apple I don't see how they could be
releasing this product without an event
so personally now that apple is doing
these online streaming events where they
are pre-recording everything it's almost
like why would you not do an event it's
easier it's safer it's more cost
effective and if you have a new product
launching that's going to be a really
crazy seller a lot of people are finally
going to want to update from their old
designs and stick around for a long time
that would make sense so personally I
feel like if they're not doing an
October event which they have done
October events for many many years it
would absolutely make sense to maybe
push it back till November where you can
release some of these products and then
potentially talk about the Mac Pro that
we've been waiting for for a long time
with Apple's two-year transition from
Intel that they talked about those two
years are up this November from when
they launched the original M1 chips and
if we're going back to WWDC when they
announced Apple silicon well it's been
two and a half years now so they should
at least announce it and of course we've
had many leaks about that system those
are actually in the wild being tested by
Engineers different versions of them so
that has to be coming and now production
is ramping up for different machines
like the 16-inch MacBooks within a Max
that were delayed for a while the Mac
studios are getting a little better so
it definitely can't be that much of a
production problem and we've even had a
lot of info on the 27-inch IMAX and iMac
Pros those are out in the wild multiple
versions I'm going through uh in the
latest ones having the new high-end
chips with the new redesign so all of
that is in the works with the Mac minis
with these new MacBooks we have those
iPads with the cad leaks that came out
there's just so much products that need
to be released so it just seems weird
not to really even have an event so
maybe they could still do some of these
products that are gonna have minor
refreshes do that as a press release
here in October and then in November do
something major because we know that
when they do a major event like that
when they have all that footage they
have that all attention that does spread
the news way better I think sales are
better too after a major event like that
instead of just dropping something
online that doesn't get as much coverage
so that is personally my opinion we are
excited about these new products some of
them we've been personally waiting for
for our production here on YouTube to be
able to get to be able to use like that
27 inch iMac those are great machines
and of course we want these through
these new three nanometer chips uh
vadim's been talking about that for a
long time the production is there so
hopefully Apple will surprise us and
we'll have better news instead of the
news that we're getting recently so
thank you guys for watching if you guys
want to see more videos we have some
more coming up on the new iPhone 14 plus
and how that's going to compare with the
pros as well as more comparisons I'm
going to do a comparison with the iPhone
14 Pros against a professional camera
that's 50 megapixels a very expensive
setup so if you guys want to see all of
that click that Circle above to
subscribe check out one of those great
videos right over there this has been
Max and I'll see you in the next video
[Music]